[SPEAKER_03]: Third of Wealsun, as the party begins to approach the inner sanctum's guards.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, hobgoblins over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: You begin walking up and you see a hobgoblin there, a hobgoblin here, and they're basically guards there.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy is wearing a breastplate as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Same thing you're wearing.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's got the red mark on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, Merrick, you know that around the corner, that's the door that goes into the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's where you need to get to.
[SPEAKER_03]: Your guys are kind of whispering.
[SPEAKER_06]: And this...
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you see the outside building?
[SPEAKER_06]: So this tower, basically we went in here and we're marching across this here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Would there be another tower here yet or no?
[SPEAKER_04]: This is where the Inner Sanctum is.
[SPEAKER_04]: These towers are part of the Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I'm with you now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what he was saying was, when we went into the big tower, we came out, and I believe we're on this, the inner sanctum is this section right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it this section that includes these two towers?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, it's this section with the two towers.
[SPEAKER_03]: You guys are marching through here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but on the lower level, not on the topmost.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're on the level right below this.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the topmost, and this is the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_01]: So as we come in, we turn right, and there's like a doorway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does that make sense?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm going to cast...
[SPEAKER_00]: Charmed person at the bigger of the brutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys begin walking up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I notice that he starts to...
[SPEAKER_04]: Hang on, hang on.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys are walking up, and you notice this guy that's wearing a breastplate.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: And he kind of looks over at you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're going to cast Charm Person?
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm going to walk like I own this fucking place.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, you cast Charm Person.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't you have the lowest rank in Farmer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, probably.
[SPEAKER_02]: This badge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's see what the range of Charm Person is.
[SPEAKER_06]: He actually has a scrub.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's 30 feet, so you're gonna cast it when you're 30 feet away.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you guys are marching up, and you're 30 feet away, and it's dark.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, I mean, the guy has dark vision, but it's hard to make stuff out.
[SPEAKER_03]: And at 30 feet away, you're this guy, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: So, right when you're here...
[SPEAKER_03]: And you guys are just marching forward.
[SPEAKER_03]: I prepare a spell.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Suggestion.
[SPEAKER_03]: Suggestion?
[SPEAKER_03]: For eight hours.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ooh, rub it raw.
[SPEAKER_00]: You cast your own person on him, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you and says in Hobgoblin,
[SPEAKER_06]: Anybody understand that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna walk right up to him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Just go walking right up to him.
[SPEAKER_06]: You want to get right in his face?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: With your costume?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna walk right up to him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right in here.
[SPEAKER_06]: And not really look at him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not really look at him.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna go...
[SPEAKER_06]: You just say gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling gobbling
[SPEAKER_00]: I was gonna say, don't they understand goblins speak common too, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just gonna say, pardon my general, his throat is sore.
[SPEAKER_04]: You walk up and say, excuse me, his throat is sore.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like to make my suggestion now.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is a DC-15 roll, and it's performance.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I make my suggestion now?
[SPEAKER_00]: 7, 17, plus 6, 23.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'm not stopping.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you just walk to the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm just walking.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you walk up to the door, and it's locked.
[SPEAKER_06]: So grab my keys.
[SPEAKER_06]: And start opening it?
[SPEAKER_06]: Start opening it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, the hobgoblin looks at you and says, why are you speaking as a human?
[SPEAKER_00]: We're not among them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oopsies.
[SPEAKER_05]: My bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: I love him just go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gollygoo.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, no matter.
[SPEAKER_04]: Why are you here?
[SPEAKER_04]: You unlock the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: What are the rest of you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do the rest of you go around?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm trying to follow.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the rest of you basically walk around this goblin.
[SPEAKER_04]: This hobgoblin just says, he's just looking forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like he's, you know, I'm gonna let the big boys talk.
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously there's some conflict.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you say to him?
[SPEAKER_04]: Unimportant business.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you speaking to Vitoli?
[SPEAKER_00]: As a matter of fact, we are.
[SPEAKER_05]: He goes... Well, he has the rank.
[SPEAKER_05]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the keys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Goodbye.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the door unlocks.
[SPEAKER_03]: The six of you... Well, the funny thing is Folsom talking to this guy distracted him from everything else.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the six of you just walk in through the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lock it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You shut the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need some axe.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you lock it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there is a bar.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you guys want to put that in.
[SPEAKER_06]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, so you guys put the bar down.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know what's in front of us, but I know what's behind us.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're leaving an awful lot of unresolved trauma behind us.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why I've got a bar, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everybody, let's get a stiff drink before we go further.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I've got one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you enter kind of an area that is 25 feet wide.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, there's that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need the, where's my, oh, there it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, marker, I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, did we all hear what that guy said about are you here for the Toli?
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that in common, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, he did.
[SPEAKER_03]: He was speaking in common.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I look at you because you've been here before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does this mean if we're in the inner sanctum?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that door?
[SPEAKER_00]: In the inner sanctum?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, would that have been the barrier?
[SPEAKER_01]: From the keep to the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's one more over here, but you are basically in the guard room.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, if you get this far, you're like right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but we don't know yet because I'm thinking a fairwind's been compromised.
[SPEAKER_01]: If fairwind's in on it, we need to know how far we've gone into the same place because this seems like real lightweight stuff if there's fairwind and a hundred or fifty dudes of his that are like, you know, holding up in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty dudes is not going to hold fifty dudes in there if they wanted to sally up.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, that's what I'm thinking as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys walk into this area, and it's lit, but empty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nobody's in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: How far does this go?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it sanded?
[SPEAKER_03]: It doesn't, but it's like, I'd say another 30 feet that way, and then there's another door like that one.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, it's another door like that one to another area.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there a bar on that door as well?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, and it is barred already.
[SPEAKER_05]: You say this is the way?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, you turn around.
[SPEAKER_03]: And come to another door right here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And once you go through that, you are in the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_03]: You've never been past this point.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that is closed.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's closed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously, if it's barred or anything, it would be from the inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so if we can get into it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: You got the key?
[SPEAKER_04]: Keys.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll actually drop the crossbow, grab my sword, and my shield ready.
[SPEAKER_06]: The door's unlocked.
[SPEAKER_03]: It opens a little, making it clear that the inner sanctum has been compromised.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of you hear voices, faint voices, talking.
[SPEAKER_05]: Off in the distance.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not gonna move a muscle.
[SPEAKER_02]: Somebody needs to listen.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I didn't get my deuce.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me put my homoculi in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seeming lizard, get in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dude, I'm getting ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rope chopper.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry, sorry I busted you out on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I go ahead and pull my toad, also, out of like, you know, my robe, and I like, put him on the floor and send him forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have a lizard toad.
[SPEAKER_05]: But that toad has ripped you so much.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's not a semen toad, Darren.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've drank with that toad.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's the hematode.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so, your homoculi crawls along the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, hold on.
[SPEAKER_06]: Here we go.
[SPEAKER_00]: This way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, let me get on the side of the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're right here, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, you guys are hanging out here, and you want this thing to crawl on the edge of the wall, and you want the toad to move along the front wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the toad's going to just be along the line of the bottom and the crack.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yours is going to be actually on the wall, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, on the wall, on the side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to follow the voices?
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, okay, what do I see out of this hallway?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, so...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm looking for guards.
[SPEAKER_03]: Basically what happens is it goes forward and then this way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then there are stairs going down here.
[SPEAKER_03]: This goes off this way.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which way are the voices?
[SPEAKER_03]: This way.
[SPEAKER_03]: You see, as the homoculi gets to here, you see a hobgoblin wearing a birthplace standing right there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why don't I take my homoculi and go down this way?
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to take your toad and go a different way?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to keep my Toe just here in the shadows, and I'm going to use him if we need him as a distraction for that card.
[SPEAKER_02]: Trust me, we've done this before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to take my homochemite, and I'm just going to crawl around there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so he crawls along the wall this way, and down.